all right new you guys it's he karo I'm
back again I assume the sound is good
this time if it's not good you guys
should let me know before I dive right
in and start playing but I was testing a
little bit earlier so I assume that it
should be fine if it's not fine
well some of some one of you guys have
told me in the chat obviously so um so
let's see who's who's gonna show up here
so I'll just wait a few seconds for you
guys um just south so do I sound good or
not let's do a final I figure out okay
good I do sound good so today I'm
probably gonna listen to some music
while I play so just giving Woonsocket
alright awesome okay so I think today
I'm gonna try and break break Magnus's
what's the thirty forty seven or
something and blitz so let me see what I
can do
just give me one side only put some
music going start start rocking and
rolling I don't put on put on
let's see so okay so I'll start with
playing this guy's legacy yeah so I'm
gonna play standard maybe we're goes in
something a little bit different so this
would be 5 H 6 probably takes Queen B 3
place c 5b 3 knight c6 probably this
would be 5 or d c5 forget exactly how
this line goes but maybe d4 okay I'll
try de for here try something a little
bit unusual try to make it a bit messy
probably he'll take with the night maybe
he'll take with the pond
so Bishop b5 I could take let's see
so Bishop b5 hmm
so if I take takes takes rook b1 well I
don't have a choice I kind of have to
start moving anyway so it's gonna take
on b4 I'll take on b2 rook b1 now I've
got cleans u6 here maybe but nothing's
gonna Castle Bishop just H 3 or maybe
Bishop H 3 right away but any castles
feels like there should be something
here or but like I'm maybe Bishop a5
Brooke b2 Bishop d3 okay why not much
I'll try it I don't know if it's any
good but let's see takes Bishop d3 then
he's got Queen d4 takes ministers - ah -
no I don't know so okay I'm just gonna
have to start blitzing moves now oh I'll
give up the all I didn't get the two
works for the queen he's got two works
upon but I think my bishop might be
slightly better than his Knight here so
we'll see 94 so there should be four
probably Bishop d5 and Queen e5 or 2016
to five depending what he what he wants
to do
so we'll see
okay so I see you guys are counting at
the same time so I'll try to pay
attention when you guys are chatting
let's see so okay so he's so he does
play after I have Queen g5 I think I
mean I've Queen g5 maybe even Queenie v
or Bishop d3
I mean Queen g5 someone that I like I
also like Queenie 525 work b7 Bishop d3
or takes takes let's play Bishop d5 try
to see where he's going with his rooks
first like he's got rook e1 but e 2 is
hanging Goti 7 hitting c5 and e3 which
so I'm gonna go Queen e7 probably 4 here
but I'm not sure ok so cam 2 assault
takes are probably rooks e2 Queen a3 or
Rick c2 Queen d6 maybe hitting h2 the
key here is if I can get the C pawn
rolling then I should be completely fine
because the bishop is better than the
night if I can use the bishop to get the
pawn locked on c4 so work up c1 so now
I'll take H to throwing a shock it's
still pretty pretty even but I feel like
it's starting to get to the point where
it's a little bit dangerous for white so
King f1 I can take 8 - yeah why not
let's have some fun if he takes I've got
Queen each one and I pick up the rook on
c1 so 94 so I'll just go back to d5
maybe that wasn't best if maybe he's got
a 4 brookie goes King to one Queen g5
came to tickle him a little bit and I'll
put a 5 although now I give rook c5 rook
c5 maybe slightly annoying play a four I
guess
now if he takes a pun maybe I've got a
community forum but should be three like
really crazy uh trick here
so he does take and I'm gonna I'm gonna
get a trick with Bishop to b3 I think
I'm boom boom goes the dynamite still
probably a draw with correct play but
I've got more time so I don't think this
is gonna be a draw so I'll throw in a
check
Queen d2 hit the pawn on e3 and then
here's Knight a5 maybe it's a good move
actually cuz he's got rook h6 so I could
play h3
I think I'll click Queen d3 can G 84
I'll play like Queen c3 get out of any
mate threats on h8 throw in a check
let's throw another check throw in an h3
so now I'll take play g4 takes so I'm
probably I'm definitely gonna fly back
in here whether I can actually win this
pawn is another question entirely
so okay finally he cracked so King
before and now I was gonna drop the
knight or he's got rooked b5 rooks no I
know I just checked pick up the night
and swung down okay fine so she wants to
play I'll give her a game quickly so
we'll see umm let's see what she's gonna
do here fine d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 pretty
random so far play a benoni possibly or
Knight f3 I guess is a move
how can not be boring I'll play b6 if
she plays Knight f3 if you probably
doesn't want to play Benoni but as soon
as I say that she plays d5 so any six b5
probably 46
Bishop d3 b5 maybe c4 b for maybe Bishop
g4 also I think I'll just play Bishop g4
97 and miss b7 to fish before L sluggish
b7
Mamamia I go again my my how can I do
Mamamia
and that's all singing for now I'm gonna
get back to playing blue since the day
we started did I ever let you go Mamma
Mia
go again oh my how can I resist you not
my mia
so Rickie one I'll just take this is
actually pretty even right now it's a
quid bish Buffy
okay let's put on some other music
that's that that musics not getting done
in this game so ninety-one just gives me
a free paw not really so if I take take
fish eat for Ricki a fish page seven so
I'll just put like rookie seven try to
hit the pollen from another angle
probably 93 g6
thrifty - I play h5 maybe they'll play
h5 just to cover all these squares that
are no exchanges
so queen G 356
hmm Queen g5 I actually missed that
that's my problem yeah actually I really
thought was stupid Queen g5 yeah it was
really stupid that's just ridiculous
wander by me um but I still work d7 to
protect the Queen and next we will move
the night away
on our plate i7 offer exchange
it probably takes takes and I'm slightly
better Exorcist blocky upon on t5 say do
you remember ba de ya September ba de ya
never was a cloudy day I never claimed
to be a good singer by the way so to
those of you who are thinking that I'm
trying to a debut for a future album
that's not happening I'm just having
some fun with you guys
so King King II 193 now I could play
Knight f4 it's still actually pretty
even actually night before I'm just
gonna put my work back on d8 I don't
know if that actually makes any sense
but so a3 tonight a for now I'm going to
try and bring my king closer like king
g6 and something if I can
oops free pond
Kings c5 I guess just get the king all
the way the pawn and also know maybe
I've got B 4 B 4 B 3 I'm just living on
here so it's pretty useful and I'm Way
up on the clock which also doesn't hurt
so hopefully Knight g5 probably Bishop
g2 and now I'll just go 97 Knight f6
I'll take with the King I could have
taken with the palm then I thought King
c3 rook d4 so d1 Knight f6 t6 king c5
and now I'm just gonna pick up the pawn
to c3
I could take that's it okay so rook e1
just be for it's just uh just
technically just win it so I'll play
rook e6 try to force the exchange I get
rookie to
and so she resigns okay cool I'll play
another one one more and then I'll get
back to the task at hand d4 Knight f3 c4
probably Knight c3 although why am I
playing the same opening that we're
playing colleges reversed
the 52 takes takes
when this day it's a kind of magic
and itsx will play c6 magic
kind of magic it's a kind of magic and
the only one
but inside of me
it's kind of magic player q1 try to
force her to take one of these ponds
sorry - Tessa analysis content is a
little bit weak right now something I'm
trying to like sing at the same time so
yeah actually as far as you guys need to
say putting music on the stream the
problem is I've tried before to do that
and it's just mess up the whole I've
tried that before it just it hasn't
worked so that's why I'm not doing it
right now so I tried in the sound which
is too too high so that's why I'm not
doing that right now play Knight b3 9595
the bish bump e7 is a very poorly placed
error
[Music]
kind of magic and the only one that
lasts a thousand years
[Music]
i da tile place c5 shut this bishop down
about rook d4 Knight g5 or cage 494 out
for all kinds of uh all kinds of things
coming here am I worried about night
before I don't think so
thank you at a dr. FERC on so lets us do
digestive a spike my drink no they
didn't spike my drink I'm just having a
good time today I mean why not it's it's
a beautiful Sunday afternoon so why not
have a good time
all right let's see what else can I put
on us and some other stuff that's gonna
be good so she wants to go on a cheese
sub and I presume I mean I want to go
like 92 94 96 you my world and I get
from me you can go your own way go your
own way you can go your own way and I
just blundered a family fork here
because of the pen on the Queen so
alright let's see okay so that's two
games so I'm gonna get back to see if I
can get back to playing some other
people again but hope she enjoyed those
games so yeah so so nice comment in the
chat someone says I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be to Magnus raid America two minutes
later ends up singing bad a band Queen
songs playing 1955 I am Alexandra
Protoss ha ha that's a good one okay
actually no I don't want to play this
guy 3 2 I'll plant 3 oh I'm not gonna
play 3 2 3 2 is a little bit too on too
slow for me right now so see soju garage
doesn't want to play who else is there
I can play so lack if he wants to play
there's bortnik let's see someone was
gonna want to play chess Queen okay so
he'll play three oh okay so let's see
didn't dumb
tonight of three what to do I'll just
play stander for a bit
III play Bishop d6 castles maybe Bush
would be to place c5 I could also take
this would be four maybe I think I wanna
place see if I've tried to play really
active if I can
all right moving on mates III I could
take I could take Queen at five maybe
takes try to find a way to keep it messy
so I'll play knight c6
the Turkish he began to speak people
sky slowly my slow what's going on
throwing a check King out one Bishop
sheet for probably
so a three go back to e7 to keep fish
Cossacks to know and hold them know when
to fold them know when to walk away
know when to run the couch or money not
the table
Tom dealings done okay fine I'll stop
saying it's that someone's annoyed so 95
I'll play Queenie six takes takes so I
maybe c5 I'll play c5 or p8 work d8 put
some pressure on this be 3 PI
I'll go at rook b8 try to put pressure
on this pawn play a five but I'm just or
Bishop f8 a lot of possibilities here I
think I'm gonna play work b6 maybe a
double maybe play work a6 but just feels
like the rook belongs here so it goes
Queen c3 could play d4 Bishop f6 I'll
play bish buffeted what is uh since I
see some of these comments what does
that show where the guides in the where
the guys in the taxi or he like drives
were on celebs and like sings their
songs its Quincy to play play a five try
to open it open up the G file now
because now I've got Queen g6 also the
rook on d6 now has a lot of roof g6
rookie h6 many ideas sandstorm doesn't
have lyrics you guys why would you want
me to sing seeing a sandstorm there no
lyrics I mean I know the song but so
Queen c4 I can take I could also play
work d5 I don't really want to play rook
d5 here but if I can't he takes it so
better move like fine I'll split work d5
try to keep it complicated so takes
takes probably working on Queen f7 or
something or queen c6 maybe I'll play
Queen c6
so I take takes but a three
I try my luck old pot would be
interesting but I mean the problem is my
Spanish isn't good enough I don't know
the lyrics that wall bishops III know I
just blunder something here maybe rook
c5 takes f3 Bishop III so play a six oh
well I mean a six was to get her off the
dark square and then try to win with the
pawns on the Kings side but play someone
dance
California dreamin Wow that would be uh
[Laughter]
yeah that's not a California dreamin
I'll be in California sue I mean
California soon sorry oh you want to
sing a blue that would be a pretty
random actually said I'm feeling so blue
whatever not my song right now just a
brown sky is gray
on a winter's day if I was in LA
California dream such a winter's day ok
before I'll play a three try to do
something beef or something like that
and maybe see for Bishop c2 or B for a6
b4 c4 Bishop c2 if he takes I'll take
with the C pawn I mean probably either
way so now I'm gonna play it for a 45 or
85 so f5 now I'm 9h for but I think a 4
it gives them g5 probably I can play g4
which is double ice I'm gonna play
Knight H for those so that I've got 96
I've got community h5 but also maybe
some f3 ephors or g4e 4 is just a matter
of what which setup he goes with
chief five Wow okay so now when I play
Knight G six hit the rook please I
thought about Queen h5 but any of King
t8 and knight c6 Bishop ei with a with a
very nasty pin so work h7 now I'll play
g4 because if he takes out this bit
don't long diagonal there's got to be
some kind of tactics of castles and I'm
gonna hit him on the other side with b5
oh dude is he of 94s bishop protected
maybe he does but I lucked out City case
I take a knife Queen e6 track so it's a
inadvertent blunder that actually isn't
a blunder so just seven so now I'll take
he'll take on a five take on e7 probably
he'll take with the night yeah I want to
play which I'll play work b2 probably
Brooke be one was better work before was
better give him clean a5 maybe maybe it
wasn't quite right but
rook c5 alive bishop c6 a rook c5 is
gonna go Bishop c6 and bsx trapping my
rug so knight c6 so now I'm gonna pull
over p1 with the intention of sacking
but by going Knight a5 now he gives me
night f3 and if I I get up this knight
on e5 with this outpost he's in real
trouble so he's gonna stack obviously on
e5 so Queen d2 tell him to go for Queen
d4 I can play Queen d4 don't have to I
want to I'll take with a steep on now
the knight on e5 is kind of out of play
rook e8 King f1 I'm gonna play where he
one try to exchange rooks on the Open
File b5 King G to his Knight is really
kind of bad here so now I'm gonna try to
go the other way
rook e1 is possible a4 maybe g3 lot of
pop since here um I think I'll just go
rook e1 now I don't play Bishop g6 and
try to force an exchange of bishops
basically I want I want to force an
exchange so that I can get my rook
behind and then attack as pawns like g5
h for a4 get the work behind and if he
doesn't then I can because of the
because of the way the pawns are I can
also just take and then go King you to
f3 achieve four and collect the other
way so g4 but now I just take and I just
play work h1 and his pawn tank he's
gonna lose he's gonna lose some pawns
so I'll play Sicilian this time a3
original I'll play g6 H four okay this
is gonna be some kind of weird game I
don't know a knight c3 but Bishop g7
he's probably gonna play h5 or this
Bishop c4 now I'll play h5 stop him from
going h5 and d6 I don't know if this who
this favor is exactly with this h4 h5
thrown in he's got g5 but I'll play a 6b
b5 and Brooke because now like I don't
know if he is gonna Castle short okay so
play b4 I'm just gonna Castle I think
and he's got this long diagonal here but
it shouldn't be that big of a deal if I
play this correctly so night h7 maybe
wish page six probably or at for both
are possible so f4 I could take all the
stake I think I'll take I don't know if
I'll probably will take with f-pawn each
pot is more natural but by taking what
the H pot I can go east six and it's not
really clear how he gets like g4 okay f5
in but he's just gonna go caveman and
try to I don't know kimchi to work h1
but the problem with this is not now I'm
just gonna try to to force everything
open
so please see three which is really
suspect I mean I played d5 he wants to
go a five nine up to takes Knight f6 so
I can't let him close it like that so II
5f5 is not good so I'm thinking maybe
I'll just play f6 and who knows what's
going on yeah I think I'm just gonna
play f6 and who knows what exactly is
going on here because I mean he does
have a free pawn here but if we exchange
I'm gonna get 95 9 f3 with uh with some
some forks against the king of the Queen
so it takes now I can take either way I
think I'm gonna take with the I'll take
with the Queen just so that I have like
Queen h4 ideas here
he takes I'm gonna take or not take I
think when I play Queen h4 I think I'm
gonna try to meet him now I'm just gonna
try to like kill him on the edge file
Sarika
- okay so wants to go the other way okay
so now I actually missed work H - that's
her that he wanted still protected
that's actually really annoying so like
take I'm not really crazy about this
position but it's still kind of kind of
okay I mean it should be proud probably
it's still okay for me but I've kind of
like bungo a little bit g3 work g2 g3 or
q2 doesn't really do anything special d5
maybe d5 takes 97 suspect okay so I'm
just gonna okay let's see time to figure
out what I'm gonna play 58 I gotta start
moving faster I'm way down on the clock
right now 93 I was like d5 now and play
97 I just give him work H 294 enough
eight I still have some cuz now I can
take a now night on g4 his hanging free
piece free piece
Queen tree - I'll take and play I can
take a four I can play Bishop wait no
there's about five I cannot do guess
I'll take here it takes rook c8 maybe
somehow this got way too complicated for
no no reason Raleigh okay Chuck Bishop
buff one take teenage - I'll throw in
another a check or not no I'll play
pitch about five because he's got no
meets here so my queen covers g7 I've
also got a rook C - threat so let's see
so I mean he's got a deal with rook c2
which is very serious threat so he he
just he does this but the problem with
this is that I think he's just he's
gonna get her wait I say if I take hip
Queenie someone with a draw and I don't
want to give him a draw so oh whoa
terrible gonna have to like flag in
somehow
yep blunder
blunder town whoo whoo that was close
way too close
oh I wasn't expecting him to throw play
check but I actually do we place in the
first games colors reversed I think I
played where it goes in the very first
game against him so maybe not maybe I
maybe it's the first thing I played
earlier 85 just III see so so let's play
Bishop t3 pretty standard stuff here any
three he'll take obviously I'll take
actually got one P 56 mmm okay I'll play
e4 takes just castles like rook e1 or
this is rather bad for block I think but
not not not really ideal
so c5 wow that's gutsy I'm gonna play d5
Knight f6 okay maybe play Queen c3 if he
takes I'll take with what rookie for
take so we're gonna play some kind of
endgame here but he is a he's a
compromise pawn structure here so I
really want to get like Knight h4
bitched about five
Oh Clinique YouTube issue 5 to be a
problem I really wish I could got a 4 B
3 so he gets B 5 has got some
compensation so I don't play Knight H 4
but if he goes B 5 I go fish about 5 to
force exchange of bishops so you can't
get his pawns rolling rolling really
fast
not yet at least there should be 5
rookie 2k8 play rook e1 ah I just
blundered Bishop e2 oh geez
oof terrible but now I'm gonna have to
go for a more swindle this is gonna have
to be swindle town so he's gonna take
take fish bay 3 rook d7 I'm still only
slightly worse probably despite its
ridiculously bad blunder p8 now I could
take which would be interesting I don't
know if it's good oh why not let's go
for it let's see he's gonna take o g4
create a square for my king but also now
I've got this outpost on a five if c4 I
go rook c7
so it's not a not so simple so please
this would be for the night of 5c for
works of 7 c 3 d sub C 2 D 7 C - D 7 I'm
in time ok so now I can okay I'll just
take and I'll grab the pons and now
we're back to Kings you to have a for I
can go like rook c8 probably or rook C
for maybe 33
I'll play h4 to cut the King off and now
I'm gonna go for me go for like this all
this kind of stuff so King c7 King G at
night h6 probably and I'm gonna take now
I've got her discovery picking up the
rook on d3
let's check play another Sicilian H for
Bishop g7 6 is gonna play something no
plane I have sticks to cover h5 d 6
maybe five maybe v4 so now he's gonna
stock up on I don't is he is he actually
gonna take he is gonna play this okay
I wasn't sure if he would actually stop
the exchange like this you're gonna
force him to play off three now here I
could play e5 so I've got Kleenex for
Chuck maybe yeah why not
- not about this clean h4 check which is
really really nasty oh sorry you said
the lighting is too edgy
okay I'll close the close the blinds and
turn all my lights on give me a second
oh and look at that I go to close my
blinds and he resigns how how generous
of him that's nice
this is 795 take 694 thanks consul c4 I
think this is some this is some ancient
theory from 10,000 years ago takes Queen
B 3 C 2 D for a six I think this would
be tooth got to be the right move B 5
wow I'm gonna take this would be 7 C 4
maybe Bishop f3 or C 4 both are possible
C 4 looks more correct somehow something
to play it because also I want to open
up this long diagonal as well so he
plays the e 6 which he does now I'm
gonna go
I could play d4 maybe play like play
like towel or something just starts
acting but I don't play Bishop etudes
now if he moves the bishop he hangs a
pawn and I'm also threatening to go d4
now so it's a little bit here a little
bit little bit messy for guac takes I'll
take on b5
I mean he's in trouble here so it's
gonna be hard to develop so Bishop g7 I
just take the pawn and now I could play
d4 maybe yeah I don't play d4 cuz now I
shut the diagonal like he he wanted to
go d4 and open the diagonal but I
playing d4 I just shut it down it's not
about these two pawns and he can't open
this long diagonal so now I just go
Bishop e5 and yeah his pawn is stuck no
no no maid on g2 and also his King is
really really bad they placed here
okay so a five I could play rook e1
Bishop d3 a lot of a lot of good moves
here a four gives them this outpost on
d4 so I'm just gonna play brook c1 try
to invade on the C file f6
wow that looks very very wrong I'm just
gonna throw in a check he's gonna have
to go to a fakes it he goes at e8 then
he runs into a bishop c7 I could play
just gonna play before threaten
another shock he goes King g7 which I
expect and I'll play work c7 or rook e1
maybe either way the positions pretty
pretty miserable for black so he resigns
okay so let's sit six down four to go
d4 Knight of 6 e 6 9 f3 I'll just play
I'll play something uh I mean I guess he
I guess he's gonna insist on playing e3
that I'm gonna he's gonna force me to
like play aggressively than I will
so so yeah let's see what he does 93
I'll just take and now we're going to
playing some kind of uh we're gonna uh
playing a I want to play this one okay
so we're going to playing basically this
this weird like weird NIM so I think
except somehow the configuration looks
slightly odd I think because normally
it's like Bishop b4 a3 bish b7 and
without a3 a little bit different but
anyway
- Bishop a4 I could play b6 now probably
why not ah but now he'll take and play
b4 is that his intention I guess
that is his intention so I'm gonna play
Knight e4 try to force him to exchange
the night so that he doesn't a b5
undermine the night Queen c2 I could
play f6 f6 b5 takes takes Knight e4
looks ok I don't see anything wrong with
it at least on first glance so I'm gonna
go for it
f6 also restricts the e5 square is no 95
now
so I mean I'm not I'm not sure I mean he
plays rook b1 I can play b5 if that
looks yeah I don't really like it but by
playing Murphy one now I can take if he
takes of ePHI d4 I get the whole center
so he's gonna have to take with the
b-pawn which is not what he wants or he
can do this well take B 5 and I'm gonna
go d4 next move he'll probably sat
mm-hmm okay I'm gonna play Bishop b5 so
he doesn't get b5 is if g 7d for queen
g3 is a problem so he takes but can't I
just play rook up seven and I'm not just
up like oh I'm gonna end up up a whole
rook here Queens g3 King f8 and I've got
no problems
but I I mean so he takes all play Bishop
f6 takes takes basically if I can get it
down to where it's just rooks on the
board his pawns are gonna be a lot less
effective where's what more pieces on
the board it's different so like here
for example I'm just gonna give up this
d5 Punk's it doesn't even matter because
it only works on the board these pawns
it's gonna he needs all his pawns to to
create any threats so he plays Queen d2
so now I'm gonna play d4 c6 well it's
clear if d8 and as you see like the
pawns are not really going anywhere in a
hurry so lady three maybe just play d3
q1 I'm gonna play Queen a4 because
basically now I'm just gonna try to
force my pawn down to d1 and his pawns
are very slow here as we can see
maybe it's see snow see something I just
take Queen c7 so Rick III he wants to go
over g3 I guess and if I take if I take
on a4 I'm threatened Ritchie 3 I've got
King h8 Queen c3 Queen d4 and I'm fine
and Queen B - Queen d4 same thing so
he's got and if he doesn't do that I
mean so clean c3 I just play Queen d4 c7
I just take because I'm Queen c7 I've
clean a one with the back rank mate so
there should be two I have three takes
tanks please g3 498 I'll play c3 here
a5 when I Knight f3 are now I'll play a
3 a 4 a through is slightly annoying so
96 Ricky 1 now I'm gonna go like Queen
c2 Knight f3 basically so you place II
thought I salt take well surely take the
night Queen C to play d4 kick the knight
back and maybe I'll play c4 actually 94
looks like a weird move I don't
understand what I chew for does close
kick his knight back now place c4
probably takes takes not sure what he's
gonna do here
a four okay so if before I guess he
wants to take now I could always take on
a four maybe before he'll trade
everything on c4 and then he'll play
Knight d5 so that's why I don't want to
go b4 CD five takes takes ninety five is
fine I'm gonna do something weird I mean
I'm gonna I'm gonna grab this pawn he
gave me a free pawn I might as well try
and take and see uh see how he wants to
play this so he takes I'll take takes
for Queen eight five
but Queenie five what did I see her I
saw something or I'm just bad rookie
seven maybe doesn't look quite right
um I'll play c5 maybe c5 Knight f5 what
was actually I've got to start moving
faster again I'm Way too slow today you
should see three Queen 846 Bishop b4
night before four minutes before DC for
no that's no good
actually I'm way down on the clock and I
so I just kind of have to start moving
this isn't really what I wanted to go
for but probably 95 this buff one night
of five I can just play like night of
three or g4 maybe
so
so now if you five fish by foreign
probably takes
yeah
tank stakes for play Knight f3 probably
we're okay for take before or p8 fish my
fate 95
I'm King G 7 this isn't really what I
was playing for at all but
it might takes off - no I don't have to
take though and then questions do I take
and try to somehow win this no I think
I'm just gonna try and hold this and
make a draw out of this if I can not
sure I can make a draw out of this
actually but definitely gonna try it
takes cash - 4 K 3
there should be 5 probably yeah d4 play
g4 at Bishop e3 he had work a1 he almost
wandered there but
actually I blunder to because I realized
he had ricky-ricky a1 in Bishop d6 which
was just winning so Jonah pre-move 96
actually he's getting mated now he just
made it himself he goes King G a truck
FA and King eh six like over cup sex oh
that was terrible
butchy - I'll play Bishop piece I'm
gonna play like my bullet my bullet
opening which is terrible but sometimes
works even in blitz the Forbush page 3d
595 it's all pretty and put a 4 or
tanker
and a p5 wow that's a original concept I
could I want to play h5 but it's not
going to work so I'll just take and
place c6 and maybe I'll play h5 next
move actually yeah why not let's see it
so he plays h4x play Knight f6 I think
I'll just play stand or just retreat
play Knight f6 try to play something
relatively boring and normal and we'll
see what he what he wants out of it
night of sex probably takes takes
someone so they saw me posting on
Facebook about adopting if that was on
the actual page that wasn't that wasn't
me I don't run the page but I did adopt
Eric Eric Rosen times two last night so
that could be what you're thinking of so
he takes I'll play a queen b7 probably
queen b5 or b4 okay
but b4 - I've night h7 now yeah I'm
gonna go to 97 and I'm hitting the rook
and I'm trying to take the bishop I'm
slightly worse here but by taking now I
can go rook c8 hitting the night and I'm
hitting the crook and now I can now I
can just take when he takes I just take
the take the night
probably he'll take on okay so he does
I'll take and now I pick up the Bishop
on e7 I'm just off a clean piece c5 will
this take
d1 just Knight f6 bring my knife back
into the game also I cover the d7 square
so I play 94 I can also just play with
c8
it's gonna I'm just gonna try to clean
clean it up and pick up the c6 pawn if I
can and so he just resigned so I was a
little bit lucky that game was not good
I probably should not have won that one
so so I'll revert back to playing the
wand in this game or maybe not let's see
play a Pyrrhic I guess
let's see how he wants to play it
so he takes I could take with the pawn
or maybe or the night I think I'll take
with a night I'm sure tables promise
probably okay but I just want to keep
the position more or less balanced 96
now maybe I'll play III no no I'll
just all take I'll just I'll try to play
this very traditionally pull at Queen d2
Bishop h6 maybe B 3 C 4 T 1 or like rook
e1 or d1 depending on how he wants to
set it up like I don't know if he's
gonna try to play C 5r e or e 5 here but
we'll see
so rook b8 now I can play b3 I'm gonna
play b3 c3 was completely fine as well I
want to see who's gonna actually play
Steve by now
I could take it's kind of risky but
since I'm playing for you guys the fans
I'm gonna go for it I'm just gonna give
the exchange I'm gonna try to like show
some really deep technical understanding
because he has he has a dark square or
weaknesses without the about that so
could take on a 6 so I could also play
b4 I think I'll play Bishop h6 first I
was gonna go rook e8 and then I'm gonna
grab a sex
because now when he goes work in a Thai
Bishop b5 hitting the rook on EI and now
I just basically want to run these
steeds like these pawns just straight up
the board
no p4 protect the pond and C 527 do I
have Queen g5 here I think I do
I'm threatening this very juicy
checkmate tactic against his King and
now he's got real problems as well cuz
like I'm also threatening to take e5
with the same maid threat so he goes
Queen e7 so I could t e5 or I can
exchange Queens I mean I really want to
just exchange Queens and one with the
pawns but I'm not sure if it's enough if
I take he goes yeah I think I should
just take in on f6 play Queen d4 my
bishop can also come back to F once
there are no threats of a back rank meet
here and as king is so weak here that
this Bishop it is just extremely strong
so okay hey no I could play Bishop b5 I
guess yeah why not there should be five
then I'm gonna follow that up with a
four so goes Bishop d7 now if I take
he's gonna go Bishop e6 I guess it still
looks very suspect so Bishop e6 just
Queen d6
if rook e8 I takes I've fished buff 1o
and I just blunder i blundered the other
way unbelievable such a good position I
just blew it all let's see if I can
somehow make this messy okay so I'm
gonna try something weird no now I'm
just obviously busted but I had more
time I've got a bunch of pawns going
down the board and I was gonna play rook
d8 so I'm gonna have to basically flak
and get really lucky and try to flag him
I've got what one piece for the Queen I
mean that's nowhere near enough but but
let's see let's see one protect the
bishop no I'm threatening c6 p8c six
Queen c4 so I'll play on h3 Queen d4 c6
I'm gonna get to bishops I mean I'm
gonna win this game the question is can
I win this game on the board as well and
in fact I'm starting to really like this
now so he takes this is really starting
to look nice efficient about 400 of c8
no a5 now my pawns are just going right
down the board to d6 yeah it's just
positionally winning now actually this
like now I'm gonna go Bishop b3 and a6
a7 be seven eight or be a queen and just
like yeah well I won that game that was
not really I should have won that much
more cleanly than I did so
all right let's whoops I just click
something wrong once I only refresh the
board sorry about that you guys
let me make sure it's correct still
still it's correct or it's not correct
let me see
yeah looks looks good still okay so
sorry about that you guys have clicked
on different a from game um see if
sérgio chests around he's not around
Kate out us I guess okay I'll try and
play him play him see if I can adopt him
d5 okay I'll play g3 Bishop g2 castles
probably eyes got Aoife is an employee
five he is okay play d4 EEP or 92 or 91
also
say tapes I'll take I have six
I think I'll place c4 and I guess we
need 4 or why not
roof t1 threaten some discoveries all
over the place Queen b6 probably night a
three if b5 just a Knight takes c6 Queen
b6 I'm gonna go Knight e3 try to get
another tempo on the Queen takes
probably Queen a6 I'll take and play
Knight d6 try to try to really take
advantage of this whole Queen side
that's kind of boxed up a little bit
might see five a plate b4 maybe or
Bishop d2 let's see
or just Eve for actually for loose
before looks very natural just efore
Bushby 3 or a 5 a 4 so let's let's see
how I wants to proceed
this plays 96 and now I play e5 here
which actually looks pretty pretty nice
or I could take he's six and then he
takes so I can take the knight take take
the bush pick tonight and take the
knight take the pawn I'm gonna go for
material because it looks I don't really
believe he has enough counter play along
the B file so it's pawn so why not
97 maybe f4 I'll just play Knight a5 hit
the pawn on a c6 and also by play Knight
a5 I get out of the attack as well so
and now now I'll play a 4 with the idea
of playing a 5 hitting the hitting the
pawn to c6 twice but also shutting down
the diagonal Bishop g4 I don't know what
that does just play with d2 because now
I have h3 as well but if I get e 5 his
diagonal is cut because of this and then
I'm also hit then I just opened my
diagonal instead so like I said before
chest is just a big game of X's this is
all about the X's
dish Bethy so he wants to hit me with
Bishop b4 so I could play Knight c4
just play 83 even why not just 83 just
stop Bishop b4 Bishop c5 is king a king
h1 I don't know if I could have gone
King up one maybe but each one looks
pretty product pretty good as well
so I'm not sure so he plays Nightbeat 6
so now I'm gonna play B 4 or a 5 I'm
gonna play B 4 so I also support the
knight on 85 now Bishop III play rook d3
force him to exchange and he's just
completely lost now because now c6 is
falling it's just a total disaster d4
Knight of 6 I have 3 I'll play b6 Bishop
d7 something a little bit random again
maybe play CC on keto c4 castles 93 94
so take there's b3 how does this line go
I haven't looked at this in a while play
d6
I guess c5 I think this there's some
game of Gibraltar that was played in
this line if I remember correctly so I
think dude I played it with black so it
has to be fairly decent so clean 87
probably work c8 Queen c7 1 or c8 push
page 6
now I could take let's have some fun I
don't know if this is good or not but
I'm gonna say since then since I'm
sacking exchanges it seems like every
game I might as well sack another one or
can you take g7
ah he took you something first annoying
okay so now I'll play Knight f6
before I think I'll just play Queen c7
a3 and now I'm gonna play e5 try to get
some kind of cut the cut the diagonal if
I can get a pawn on e4
if I get e4 I think I'm doing very well
because then his bishops locked out
likey for Queen e5 for example
Queen c3 so if I go 8-4 he just takes
obviously Sona player 58 here maybe rook
C D it was slightly better I don't know
but I'll go community 7 he probably
wants to put a bishop on c6 would be my
guests but now I can play e4 because my
queen protects the pawn positions pretty
balanced I have to say neither side
really has any kind of advantage
so a four so I don't want I don't want
to take I don't want to give him the uh
I don't want to do that so I'm gonna
play g5 and maybe go king g6 get out of
this pen King G 6 H 5 H 4 maybe because
I still I don't really H 5 y'all play
Age 5 so probably take stakes or 8 6
doesn't make sense White's white wants
to come down the a file so it I fully
expect him to do that but he plays rook
T 2 which is a good move actually
because now g5 it ain't so I can't
trading over 58 okay so I'll take and
play Queen e5 cut the diagonal now I
can't put the Queen but he does control
the D file so it's a little bit tricky
here I put III maybe take on a fiber
maybe just play h4 I'm gonna play h4
because now my advantage is here on the
Kings side to try and made him because
with the pawn at E for the bishop can't
go to g2 and protect the king I assume
he'll take on b6 will just take I'll
freedom of it and then play Queen d6 is
my guess or a queen these sticks right
away now here I can take him take a 5
maybe which is kind of weird but I don't
know if it's good or not but but why not
okay so I'm gonna go for them and take
the pawn d1 I'm gonna play a six here oh
I just wonder Bishop d7
oh he missed he had Bishop be something
which was just winning the game on the
spot I know I'll play h3 now I want to
try and meet him like rook da trip d1 so
I'll take and I'll play III
and I want to go work the a truck t1 and
Chuck made him because out the pawns
like this and he blundered that I'm
gonna up night chief for tricks I'm
gonna checking on throwing an 84 and you
see this Bishop it looks really nice on
c6 but I can't do anything so these
pawns just cover everything I think here
I mean does take and go a4 and now my
pawns again I'm just Chuck mating him
that was an interesting game well a lot
a lot of good ooh
b5 Wow okay I'll have some thought okay
p4
maybe just castles d-34 maybe d3 I don't
know I mean but I want to play E for so
please c5 I'll play e5 just castles
knight c6 92 and play something pretty
standard I think
please c4 here if I want I think I will
don't play rookie one here I guess
because he has Bishop e6 and Knight 85 I
guess he wants to take the take the
bishop instead but I was much more
worried about some Knight a5
basics hitting this pond on this
exchange I'll click H for Queen c2 he is
94 if he wants to play it I don't really
think he will but it's always there okay
so he does it
tinks I can take and play Queen d3
attacking the pawn here on d4
so queen bee 294 may be a rookie one who
wants to go Queen state three-legged
Lisi 5 this is a slight problem here
actually I don't know what to do maybe
night of 3 really 94 I feel like I've
miss played this a little bit but the
knight on e4 is very well placed still
so be 3x play rook b1 here maybe rook e1
or 53 takes takes b7 it's probably the
safest way to avoid losing so I'm just
gonna try to play the corrupt corrupt
moves here even if it takes away any
winning chances
so I assume he's gonna take on d3 most
likely I think it's actually the only
move cuz Queen off to I just take with
the night so he has to take okay three
work be seven so you can play rookie
seven but I think now hopefully work b1
which was a bad move so I gave him out
five I should have just taken and play
Brooke d1 that was bad very very poor on
my part complain i t6 maybe no okay so
I'm gonna have to take and play like h5
this is definitely not what I was aiming
for please g4 may be c5 well just play
King G - I'm not sure we want to play f5
or a five or what he's angling for so I
please King out six okay Knight f3
actually he won't take his on both palms
would be hanging so he's probably gonna
play e5 or d3 I place the e5 but now
it's gonna get messy so I've got a check
T six and I got five c5 okay six when I
can go see six take King e6 that would
be seven guys can work c8 though
and I completely messed this up
completely completely massive sob we
have to try and flak and but I'm not
sure that if I'm gonna be successful
with that
wait I just blender or splendor he is a
mean wish be through shucks mate so
too slow man too slow too slow you gotta
be faster
terrible terrible is terrible
all right so you guys are asking about
the the clicking yeah I mean I kinda
over click a lot but that's just because
I'm trying to play really quickly and
fast
so he wants to go for hg 6 so I have to
be very careful here not to get made it
gh is crazy let's say so I've caught
fish p6 maybe Ike if I take he's
probably in take with the e pawn so I
think here I'll just play King G maybe
or okay J I'll play rock Ajay
some ticks I'll take castles not here
I'm gonna grab the pawn so she for
tonight of six of each X I go King g8
and I'm pretty saved and I've also got
96 now be since he traded off like if I
get 96 and queen of eight I'm completely
fine sweet like when IH 5 plus he'll
sack so I'm gonna play 98 protect the
pawn maybe 3.96 hit the pawn on on g5
now
can be one of us to take the pawn and
now this is definitely winning if it's a
matter of playing preciseness on a play
94 put the knight on an outpost hit the
pawn on f3 as well Knight f5 so he's
trying to get fancy if I take I could
just play King f8 but I think I'm just
going to just gonna play Queen f6
sidestep any tricks oh this is bad move
because now I can take on d4 go nighty
to click Queen g7 and I want to play h5
if I can but he plays off for now I
think I will if I take I know I can I
can go eh folks on FB 5 out of 9 f3
Knight takes e5 yeah now if we move yet
he can't with the Queen ox and he hangs
the night because right now he's got a
rook and a queen hitting here so he has
to kind of play Queen h3 and stay on the
H file or else I'm gonna take call take
93 but I'm very close to being just
winning now I just add a few more good
moves so I'll play like the Bishop d7
Queen g3 and Bishop e6 hit the pawn on
c4 now
so please work you won so I think I can
just grab I don't see a reason I can't
just grab another pawn I mean really the
only danger here is that none of my
pieces are really developed so like if
you can somehow create an attack or
something like I don't even care about
these Queen side pawns I just need to
get like Knight f6 King g7 and then it
should just be winning so f d4 I'll play
Bishop e6 I'm 82 and now I'm gonna play
Knight f6 out of four point ninety four
between you two and I think I'm just
gonna play King g7 I'll just give up
this pawn I don't really care I'll play
like rookie he8 or work eight I guess
this batter
there should be three but now I just
take take Kenny - no I think I'm gonna
flick Queen before so I'm hitting the
Queen hitting the rook hitting the night
so you can't move the Queen off and once
the exchange is these just these three
pawns are gonna rule today so Queen d5
queen takes off for and that's all she
wrote
so a 600 I'll take all a night c420 7.92
so maybe Bishop g4 would be sick
something like that I don't know which
one he's gonna do 95 ok logical I could
play d4 f4 is always there
f4 is interesting I'm gonna go for off
for just to try and open the long
diagonal Bishop e6 I'll play a 3 to
cover this citizen of night before
please for kick the night to be six
probably knock lady through I guess he
is d5 maybe Queen f.2d for c3
bah-bah-bah
okay so it plays d4 someplace c3 he'll
take I'll take he's got this a pond
that's the only danger for me in this
position so I really need to like
Riemann over this night around maybe two
III one possibility I think I'm gonna
play rook gate three just to protect the
bishop and now I'm I think I'm willing
to let him take so I'm gonna go rook c1
and then do something on the C file
between D to cover the pawn everything's
solid play like I do have problems here
there are definitely some issues with my
position so I've really got to call it
with something special
I'm locally 93 c8 and now I'm gonna
start I'm gonna start trying to just go
all in Queen c7 work c1 probably
and now I'm going to try to just open up
everything at all costs all this could
be bad cuz there is nice before I guess
yeah this is pretty terrible okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna try to go to swindle
mode and see if I can't pull something
random
I guess mr. Scott works c1 though what
am i doing yeah that was d4 which is a
terrible move just I opened up way too
much stuff for him
let's see I'm like something I'm gonna
trick him again what is he doing
right
well that was so bad
geez I'm playing like 20 like a total
clown today I choose us so bad
anyway the game continued so so this
this game at least is more interesting
so okay so you can't or not but I'm
gonna go up sex obviously so takes takes
an f6
so oh wait he didn't move sorry sorry I
thought he moved okay 22 playoff six
again I'm slightly worse even in this
game so I try to do something over here
maybe some King side attack by cannon I
don't know what Queens u6 is I just give
them Queen eight six on me please Queen
c2 hmm quickly on seven
see okay if I play each 5h4 I'm gonna go
for it I'm gonna I'm gonna send that him
getting his night to be four is actually
a bad thing because even though this is
a week he has no real attacks he ran or
k7i just go Queenie six I've got h3
chief for coming so I can play h3 I'm
gonna play g4g for first week it doesn't
have point out three hitting the pawn
okay seven into 26 Queen c2 I'm gonna
play out five now this is getting tricky
for again for white though because like
okay Queen 82 now I could play it ooh
can I go f4 whoo oh yeah now I've got
mating threads
Queen d2 maybe h3 or g3 or Queenie for
actually Queen e-40 Quincy - I've got to
be careful here so maybe h3 yeah okay
let's see what he does on h3 if takes on
Queenie form about queen bee one and
queen she - no it take if he takes I
just take on G - and then he can't stop
Queens you one or a queen bee one sorry
so he takes correctly now I could just
take I think yeah why not just takes and
if d7 just rotate I think and he can't
cover me or I had queen g4 actually
picking up the rook to
free pawn
I'll take it as I was saying last night
as it quote goes we are envoys we take
what is offered I could take I think
I'll just castle no need no need to give
them Bishop to Bishop hair
submission about five I could take a
plea just play Bishop d3 why not
now maybe 95 feels like there should be
a way to just win here but 95 95 d 5 92
rock f5 yeah okay
so someone just said what am I going to
change the opponent I'll change if I if
I can get to ten in a row I get adoption
then all done I'll change
okay so 92 I'll play some random line
let's see 6 7 2 3 D 5 probably tanks he
said II 5 probably 97 96 next takes
interesting ok I play Queen c7 I think
I'll go Queen e7 so that he doesn't have
a fork so I can take it on e3 is hanging
so Queen c2 so I don't know if he wants
to a knight of fiber will play b5 maybe
or a 5 I'll play something proud I
always play g6 cut the take with a 5
square from the night and now I'll
figure it out here although now I gave
him my 4 so this could be a little bit
dangerous I don't have to actually be
very active
maybe Nike for I don't know why I played
b5 I was gonna play Knight g4 or I
should play right away just to drop the
bishop back to g7 although maybe now
Queen h4 is a threat too
so 94 I mean I could take on b2b 5 was
such a bad move I just I mean I give him
fix the structure for no good reason
I think I'll play I'll play Nike 7 I
mean I really this pawn should be back
here and this business would be on c4 so
it's just beef I was just a stupid move
so hey it's okay so now I will take it's
gonna take and maybe Knight b6 or can i
play Knight e5 and get tricky well I
think I first have to take now the
question is can I get tricky here like
95 or something I think I'm gonna try to
get tricky with 95 see if I can get
tricky with some like some rope d 8 and
again this is why playing beat another
reason out of the 500 why b5 was such a
bad move
now if he goes Queen d5 he runs into
Bush v6 her guess it's got Queen c5
maybe so he plays 95 this is begging for
tactics clean off six Queen f6 rook up
one night of two takes Queen f6 King g1
maybe Bishop east wait b6 he's got Queen
Eve for Oh feels like there's got to be
some tactics here like Queen h4 maybe
okay let's say Queen h4 h 3 maybe night
f2 and Bishop takes h3 9 of - King up to
push for h3 Queenie for night - for King
out 3 Queen f6 Queen g4 clean out for
night eh - okay I'm gonna go for it I
don't know if it actually works but I've
got to go for it in fact I have a draw
at least so why not go for it
in fact King f3 maybe I can just take
and shock him
wait cancer he takes a Chuck King out
three and the business on b3 so I don't
know about five at the end I'll tickle
him and now I've got time to figure it
out so let's see so maybe check probably
Queen a4 check check check and take take
on you to take e3
94 do I just have Chuck and night of
five and yeah and
probably a six here maybe or something
else I don't know what he's gonna do
take I'll play Bishop e2 fish buff one
maybe also as possible but just just
Knight f3 and seven I'll play d4 take
three four I'm not sure which one hold
play just plays d6 okay pretty standard
I'll play h3 stop Bishop c4 about five
I'll Castle c-45 just play a three-stop
night before also know eight four tricks
now a tricky one
stuff one
Oh someone said tickle start with the a
sir I don't know who had started with
but I heard I mean I've heard Danny say
it many times so I I don't know if
that's what it is but I mean I've heard
Danny say it's that's where I'm taking
it from so it takes I'm going to take
with a pawn and play d5
again this has gotten a little bit
unpleasant for black like night b8 I can
take out six and because I know I've got
Queenie and Chuck made if he takes so he
has to take with a pawn and now move
it's hard to believe the black can be
okay here
make these seven no no III tried
exchanges like we're bishops and get
this Knight to f5 and then then as it
would say it's it's all over
Knight of five maybe we do have Queen g3
Queen g3 Queen g5 I guess Queen g3 makes
sense and all this take take play work
b1 or theme I play broke up one hit the
pawn enough seven and now I can also
play work out three to defend from the
side so my rook is very active here
unlike where I'm b1 it would not be
active King GA now I cook the night of
five but I think I'll start with rook f3
he's gonna play rookie a but see the
rook on up three versus be one huge
difference now I can go Knight a5 okay
one King inch to now I can take I can
plead g4 I think I'll just take with
Chuck teenage Southern interesting not
the move I was expecting so now let's
see I could take Chuck take six ninety
six ninety two I'm not completely clear
I want to play Knight g4 all the dices
give him King g7 hit King's you
something probably okay so it's got a
pass to a pawn okay I'm gonna try to
simplify now though try to force it into
some kind of more traditional territory
because these three pawns even though
two of them are doubled should be good
enough to win the game here so King out
five night of 794 just gonna grab these
seven he can't take g3 cuz on a good
night taste her Oh 96 he takes okay I
guess now try to start running my pawns
up the board came out for
g5 alright is here okay one in H III
though
time to go for flash tactics I'll take
and play g6 and if you take zygote g7 I
make a second I make a queen so it
should work but yeah so now I make a
queen on this this has to be winning
somehow nice c5 you know it's eight
you can't cocaine d4 but now I mean now
I know I've passed pawns too so it's uh
so t4 I'll play b6 I'll try to play
something so I'm gonna he's gonna play
this way now okay probably five yeah
ninety-seven I have three c5 there
should be seven played this line a
million times as well I might add so
it's a queen III I'll play age six of 93
just g6 a knight c6 go I'll do something
weird I'll play g5 here in 93 I'm gonna
do something really weird it's not
threatening h5 so I'm gonna go Queen D
three queens u 6h five I don't know that
makes any sense but uh but it's an idea
that at least has some logic to it so
please Knight h5 which is kind of what I
expected and now I I think I'm gonna
take on t4 and I'm gonna castle long
rook c1 I'll go king b7 because now it's
like all those pieces are a little bit
jumbled here they're not it's not really
clear where he's trying to attack from
a 3l display King d7 get the King out of
the air play b5 about 96 night C for
coming here if you ate for I just I'm
gonna play a six and still just put the
night on c4 92 96 8 3 quickly Queen a 5
so I'm just gonna play night C for
though problem is my rook on h8 it's a
little bit misplaced I'm play a six
protect b5 now I really want to bring
this rook to like c7 or something if I
can that's long ways off but d1o play
rook c8 I see one free pawn takes eyes
got rook a one Bishop b4 this looks very
suspect because he's not really covering
anything like he can go over k1 but then
I go rookie and he's lost to a file
I've sued one I'm just gonna play like I
guess I can play rook a3 can also just
take the pawn but I think I'm gonna play
product I'm just gonna go rook c8 got my
other work in the game takes DC 5 whoa
what's that I just take Queen to Knight
c4 he wants to go see sex let's plan a
c6 and that's another adoption in the
books see okay let's see so let's see if
parka mauve wants to play he does not
want to play um is there anyone else
okay I'll play bortnik let's see what he
wants to do okay so II 45 play a scotch
night a five
d5 to the stake and play age six and
Knight f6 that's why there's no but HSV
was unnecessary because he would have
had to cancel anyway but H this is
practical just to stop there's your
chief on Knight c3 I'll castle stuff 394
is a move well I think I'll just play
Knight e4 why not about core play rook
e8 r c6 both are playable like rook e8 a
bit more right it fortunately forces me
to trade the trade the bishops now think
here is White's pawn structure slightly
worse if he can get some g4 h for an
attack then he's completely fine but but
it's a little bit unlikely he's gonna be
able to attack on the Kings side here
please rip d1 so I might take and play
and play Queen c7 to force him to take
and take and play Queen b6 and 94 maybe
that's also there I'm gonna force him to
trade the bishop so
so I should be a little bit better here
but it's not it's not really clear how
much better I am so if I take and play
queen before I think I'll take and play
Queen before because now it'd be three
I've d4 and then then he loses material
so he might have to go rook b1 or queen
d3 but queen d3 d4 a3 Queen B - Knight a
four and blah and why it's probably okay
but if I take cleaning through p7 rook
e8 it's black oak is white okay there
are not not sure I really want to do it
but I also have to be careful here not
to use too much time on this move I
could also just move up move a pawn or
something like b5 yeah why not I'll just
play b5 because now I'm threatening d4
and b2 is hanging because now after work
b1 I just go Queen 83 and be summons not
hanging so if I take rook be one Queen
and 395 that's his idea I guess takes
days rooks to see a it looks C 1 D for a
3 but I can go D for a through K
yeah probably d4 makes sense now he has
to go to a 3 only move I take he takes
and now I can take or he plays 94 ok
it's 94 I'll take it with c5 oh I keep
scheme f6
not really what I wanted to give him but
let's see okay that's the queen c3 g6
Queen d2 th7 laughs that doesn't look
right
although maybe it's still okay let's see
I don't know but Queen d2 could be a
problem here I mean because h6 is Queen
d2 keen h7 per cage for Queen d2 maybe
d3 counter woke up eight
so kini h2 is now if I take what's this
idea once go rook e8 done I've got c4
maybe c4 was better right away though I
don't know either I'm either on fire I'm
probably getting needed between a 6 to
pick up a 6 I think he Metz played this
I think I'm probably winning now Queen
a4 monogamous play like rook d8 rook da
dum Queen d6 is coming with the idea to
exchange Queens maybe if a queen d6 he's
got rook e8 oh this is tricky though so
he plays g3 which is very tricky it's
not have to be very careful so I'm gonna
play Queen c6 maybe or I've gotten hurt
I'm sure just gotta move fast what am I
thinking I didn't realize how low on
time I was you guys now I'm probably
gonna windows I'm faster
so it's probably gonna have to
and there's another one in the in the
books Wow
somehow I got way too low on ton in that
game I was in a paying attention at all
to the clock oh wow that was tough game
I don't know why I just played efore and
then Audi four just wasting comfy but
positions still probably okay
he's not gonna take on tv4 so probably
that's a bad dream of mine she threw
work out for 90 85 maybe Brooke f5 now I
could play a for all the 94 looks much
more reasonable now just d5 now I've got
the outpost with the night here so I can
just try to like click Queen d3 and like
rook b1 next move
basically I want to take the advantage
of the speed file maybe even Bishop a5
at some point
let's see it'll play five no Knight b6
now work b7 as a threat I don't play f3
consolidate I don't know if I have to
take but I feel like there's no reason
not to take so I click queenie 4 and
play rook d7 now I'm gonna try to invade
on the B file if I can't Queen up for
interesting I don't take take I could
play g3 but I don't play rook e1 ideas
work a7 or case ex works e6 and just run
the a pawn right up the board so please
see sex the repeat sex takes tanks or
gate play g3 h5o clicking off to force
the bishop to move but now he 5 is
hanging as well I can take with the
bishop or the rook Bishop takes Bishop
d2 rookie to Bishop a5 takes a takes not
clear um maybe H no h4 he's got Bishop
da so I'm gonna play work b1 here try to
force an exchange of rooks and that on
try to force an exchange of rooks and
then pick up like pick up the the pawn
or if these six rook takes a six
trust six before I take obviously I'll
remove it anyway because it's probably
gonna happen g5 King III takes takes and
surely my past pawns are gonna win one
here I would assume yeah so just resigns
d3 h6
whoa work off one what does work up one
the Queen D so I assumed him at night
off one but I don't know for sure
flavor p8 okay so clearly yeah clearly
he blundered he meant to play that right
away
okay sack it's possible it doesn't
really make sense
d4 doesn't move as well maybe what about
d4 let's see four on play p4 although I
just gave him Bishop a4 maybe that was a
bad move
I'm not sure if I'm actually much worse
here that's the funny thing like Queen B
5 now I could play Bishop b3 which I
think makes sense
look you've won I'll take cleric d8 so
he takes d3 is very weak
those 92 bishops see - maybe 94 work d4
night night a night of three though I'll
play this play Bishop e6
I have three kind of take a forty three
eyes got 95 okay so I'll just back up
then or up d8 and up d4 I can take and
play Bishop c4 so II five that looks
wrong in 55
let's fish before and I can take and a
takes and I go rook to e3 and I'm
completely fine so I've completely
equalized if we need to I'll play Knight
d5 three threes place c6 protect my
queen
okay seven you're just Queen b6
so it takes takes is if you didn't take
Iver takes g3 Rick c1 or g6 pretty
balanced but the night is better than
the bishop here at least so there should
be some some winning chances perhaps
maybe between beat one try and get
behind the rook afford to have 93 maybe
queen d8 k h7 roof d2 night off 1 he
blundered yeah he just wandered so f5
then I've got night off one anyway
picking up the bishop so I mean promise
night f1 and yeah the king is see I've
work up to 9 f 123 I can just play work
g6 and he's completely he's just baked
but takes I take and I see someone said
after Queen b6 work takes off something
but I Burke takes g3 just in case
so Queen B to f5 just place C 5 C 4 C 3
I actually could have just played out 5
2 but so have 6 no actual threats how
what's the cleanest way to win this
though all this take let's play queen g6
our clean up 5 is better
if g4i of queen g4 between d4 between d3
probably got five and then i'll queen d5
and now I've know I've solidified
everything so I just go c3 Queen b3
takes and this isn't really the cleanest
way to win but it's it's winning
okay another one another one in the
books
it's over again the same client same
kind of setup as before same positional
structure night of five play a four I
played d4 I think I'll play d4 here just
keep it more standard Queen d2 there
Trump's here for both sides I think for
for white the advantages are the two
bishops obviously for black this Knight
f5 is very nicely placed so let's see I
think I'll play Bishop buff one and
probably like Bishop d3 or something I
don't know if it makes sense if he's
gonna go push my fate there should be
four which could be a slight problem
here so let's put my queen on d3 maybe
queen bee 5 is an idea maybe at some
point plays a six will play play chief
or don't really want to play that so
I'll put it over c1 c8 maybe no Bishop
h3 or f4 hopefully g4 why not whoa 98
for wow I was not expecting that huh 4
does he have problems here with this
night this night on the rim is grim now
Bishop d3 I know I've kind of gotten
what I wanted in a way in a sense so
place age sex so I guess I'll play Queen
up to here
maybe I'm playing up five maybe I'm not
I don't know yet we night 502 a 3 Queen
b6 maybe B 4 a 5 B 5
if a for probably does King h1 sort of
d8 I'll just play a for probably chirp
lady a for anyway if this bishop before
isn't a threat now I'm gonna go out five
and it's gonna get rather ugly I think
for black because if he doesn't take
he's got problems please work a feat now
I could play f6 or wait can I just take
on e6 wait he's got Queen e6 though if I
take Queen e6 Bishop a5 9 5 GF 5 that's
also good I don't know if f6 is good or
not so I'm just gonna slow play at Queen
e3 keep all the tension in position oh
nice wonder Bishop d2 unbelievable and
now he's like now of course he has Queen
DeForest Wow yeah I'm so good for me I
can't believe I did that
let's see if I can find a way to somehow
Sal was just very unlikely but maybe
okay class 6
there's some way to play this probably
not I mean it's probably this lost maybe
yeah that's ridiculous completely
winning to completely winner
it was unfortunate
well so a three okay I'll just play
Bishop e6 get out of the way of any be
for ideas Thank You 385 now many of you
yeah I think I will play a five now
actually if a four I just played be for
my ship d2 I could take I'm well I
probably just a four is good for black
and more importantly this Bishop is
stuck behind all these ponds which is
not what white really wants in this
opening there should be one there should
be 381 and fatigue bikini of seven
probably
q4 okay it's 98
I'm gonna play f6 to protect the pawns
fish buff seven if for all this tape
tough one no I'm gonna go 95 yup see -
I'm gonna just see five it's important
just to keep keep everything behind
these ponds thank you - now I'm gonna
play g5 and lock it up this now that he
exchanged a dark square bishop I'm not
so worried about any of these threats
over here anymore
like Knight f5 doesn't worry me and I've
got 96 night of 4 if I want it I don't
have to go for it I think maybe we just
push an e6 because Knight h5 I can just
play rook work f8 so Knight a5 or c8 I
don't know why I did that
so now I smoke it should be one okay
let's see if I take I'll take and play
rook c8 takes I know but now I can just
take and go Bishop d2 96 Bishop d7 and I
should be winning d3 b 4 is a has to be
winning his knight actually here is
dominated by the bishop as well so in a
sense White's playing this position down
at ease
it's a b3 I can go b4 b4 he's 94 though
lots of if I take and go Bishop okay I'm
just taking boba ship C 1 and this must
be winning especially because now I'm
getting up for as well there should be
seven foursome back to e1 and then I go
go ship c8 and I just winning
Wow so something really interesting he
wants to give up the two bishops here
which is kind of surprising
okay so age six now the key here is I
should put my king on g2 and figure out
a way to activate this did the bishops
put them on the right right diagonals in
this position so you please clean d6 so
we should see one stop Queen d2 King to
two just got the King out of the way
I'll play rookie - so now I've worked
protects the Queen so he doesn't have
any 94-94 tricks push v3 Queen a3 I can
display rook e1 when I give them Queen
d3 or maybe I can just go Queen C 1 cos
94 I've worked d1
okay I'll try to play it play this on
this one instead just see if I can play
this for a win instead so I see maybe
King F 1 and G 2 followed by a 4
it's gonna be a long endgame here though
that I'm trying to win so we'll see
now can I take and play this I think I
can because of the because of the
placement of the pawns I think I can
play this for a win
so think here I'm gonna go King City for
so take stakes because the point is I'm
gonna go b4 and create an outside path
spawn here
wait but Knight be southern I can go
Bishop f7 he was supposed to take I
don't know what he's doing here I think
this should just be lost for for block
so I take he's gonna take now I play
Bishop f7 or Bishop g4 probably Bishop
g4 I'm just aged 592 king d3 and I had a
for King basically I'm going to play b4
and create a create a second pass pawn
so so if I take what exactly is going on
I don't understand what he's trying to
play it for so I go to h6 she's simply
Bishop a5 and force him back to AJ I
pick up this c4 pawn and okay so he's
just just losing you okay so all right
back to the Scotch we go
so probably play the same line again I
won't play h6 i don't know if i need to
but i'll do it just to be safe wow this
is fairly random don't really understand
what he's doing here this seems suspect
so take stakes sorry you guys by the way
if i'm not actually following the child
super closely right now i'm just trying
to play play good moose
well the solutions pretty ugly for ye I
mean I can place c5 for example if Queen
b6 feels like there's got to be some
tactics early clean up sex maybe hitting
the rook on the a1 and actually can't
move his knight here
no I just take the pawn black month
white might still be kind of okay but
it's definitely not gonna be easy I'll
give back something here I don't know if
this is right but it feels like a
reasonable try
now maybe III hear or Knight f3 knight
of three looks very comp ting I don't
know if it works but F why not why not
so I've got Queen g5 with me so I feel
like Queen off one is the only moving
that I can go like rook b6 worked g6 and
just like rip g6 worked g2 feels like gg
gg yo has to be GG just work g6 were she
- and so please King each one and rook
g6 gives some white like rookie 3 or
something I don't understand
roachie to Knight f3 Queen h3 is me
Knight takes up 3 Queen h3 is this
checkmate ok he just doesn't see it
so a pretty normal position again
punitively although I do have two
bishops so I should be slightly better
Wow dc4 okay if I td5 and not so sure
what he's doing
I think blackness in a lot of trouble
here to be honest
so Queen d6 so he protects the pawn now
I go clean a five maybe for Queen she's
Queen a flower protects the queen of
five looks right so I protect the bishop
I attack the knight if he moves tonight
if I've still hanging
so Jesus except like an h3 now I'm
hitting the pawn I'm still trying to
take maybe h5 how can he still be a
surviving this this is very hard to
believe maybe work up D 1 over KD 1 or
maybe just 'if you know F 4 F 4 EF 4
does not make sense
c 5 doesn't make sense or D 1 maybe do
one maybe just F 4 there's got to be a
way to just be winning here but I don't
see it
to take take 4 PA no ok I'm just gonna
start playing loose before I got down
too much time on the clock and I can't
do anything
Knight of three maybe maybe just up for
just go I just go all-in caveman style
just like go for the kill
97 Wow and I've got nothing f5 but he
has g5 maybe mmm I feel like I messed
this up a little bit still should be
fine but I'm down on the clock and
efficient it's not not very clear
whoa King h7 what's that let's take the
pawn on each floor
there's three work up to just to protect
everything
and see five wish me to kick the rook
away
if work g7 I take h5 if we're chief I've
still got Knight f3 and then II five is
hanging so yeah
let's see okay rook c5 Knight f3 94 if I
take I've got this takes e5 Knight of
two Knight g5 er doesn't make sense if I
take takes Queen h4 no tricks no no
funky tricks oh yes it takes now let's
play rock up one and everything's
protected again teenage sex Wow I think
I'll play c5 just to open it up here
because he's gonna take the knight I'll
play e4 just that's why I get the other
diagonal activated now I don't know if
it's correct but it feels like a logical
way to simplify he can take though this
guy is slippery 96 OD no I didn't have h
no not leaning fortunately
I guess I'll just play Brooke before and
try to force rook now rocks come off so
this is just winning or maybe not quite
not quite that simple wish me to but
this is just winning because rookie h4 I
can even go to a three and he's just uh
everything's boxed in rook gauge three
rupee five hit the night kini h6 I just
take and go king jutsu and the stroke
goes bye-bye
so yeah pretty good
so I'll just play d4 right away play a
five again it's gonna be probably very
similar to the last game we played so I
think though I here I did not I didn't
waste any any time so I'm gonna go
Knight c5 and probably just try to um
try to hit him right away over here so
he's gonna go rook g1 I assume err no
now I'm gonna take to try and loosen it
if he takes the pawn I want to go like
Knight a5 so okay now I can play 94
which I think I will do and I'm gonna
take with the pawn and go see five c4
here because he's played g4 so without
any extra minor pieces to trade off
material I don't think he should be okay
here so f4 as expected no I'm just gonna
play rook c8 and c4 c3 if I get the
chance feels like he's a little bit too
loose here like takes c3 and feels like
he's just too loose like he can't hold
everything together here somehow
take some the snows see three or four k3
I'll play Bishop c7 and Bishop takes out
for a while
ee five Wow bold at four play f6 f6 East
six
Oh playoffs that's just I mean I don't
know if he's playing east six or what
he's actually playing here no so okay so
he wants to play 494 I can play C - if I
take he wants to go f5 it's a very messy
position I think I'm gonna play Queen d5
here actually what am i doing that is
Queen f3
I could sack another fine I'm gonna sack
I don't know if this works but it looks
I can go rook d8 maybe takes feels very
wrong like I did something terrible
again
but f7 King f8 not really sure what's
going on though actually I could have
taking Chuck King g6 maybe maybe
although here I've got Chuck now pick it
up I guess this isn't so clear either
though cuz he's got rook takes d3
although these two pawns are extremely
strong here
this has to be winning King f2 Queen d4
I'm thinking a be to just GGO
so I'm not sure I mean this this looks
this has to be district G G c1 he has to
take and I take b2 with chocolates GJ
okay so he's gonna try to play on but
this
there's not a fortress here I'm pretty
sure that
then I can go King chief five five six I
can just throw on a check and take with
the pond
and so okay so again like play the same
structure maybe probably he'll play e5 I
don't know maybe not
okay a5 a3
it's a be 5 volts plate Queen c2 96
Knight f3 rook c8 now I could please c4
here but I don't play rook e1 play for
the same 95 concepts concept again sorry
I'll play for probably before and now
I'll play c4 we can exchange but I like
this diagonal or this diagonal it's a d4
so he doesn't want that okay which is
interesting so clear okie to rook e1 in
fact I'm going to pre move it just so
I'm sure it'll happen now I could sack
yeah let's have some fun oh it's got
work f6 oh no oh wait no no I can take
I've got rook e8 Chuck yes come on
if he takes I've got rookie a woohoo
come on
that's 99 I defeated I can just play
rook e8 even honest so he's gonna sack
his queen again but there's there can't
be a fortress here I'm going to put the
fishpond t2 and then bring the Queen to
f3
so we're gonna we're gonna play this
this line again um maybe like the 20 I
feel like this like the 20th times
played this frickin line Queen d6g 4 is
slightly wrong I think I'll take they're
gonna play like B 4 I'm just like try to
force everything off now I do it B 3 B 2
here that might be good why not
okay sex Bishop b3 first maybe do I want
to throw in Bishop b3 there should be 3
rook e1 rookie hey it takes I don't
think I want to throw it and doesn't
make sense so chief fives so if I take
you oh I just hung B - Oh what am i
doing oh I'm still fine but oh that's
disappointing
oh so annoying
play f5 here maybe try to play for the
Winstone although he just blundered here
cuz now I was just dropping upon take
with the bishop Oh Brooks c1 oh jeez
okay still probably a draw up at all
that's frustrating
maybe I can try to win this I mean
probably not though
I'll try to somehow at the very least I
can Oh a sack might work for the pawn
and make a draw so really some problems
for drawing but uh it's frustrating wait
do I have got five here after five night
at five work f3 94f I've take certain
mmm ok I'll try to try to flag it in
this one but that's gonna be a draw
though he's got too much time
so frustrating yeah so frustrating
hmm
so it's gonna play B 5 B 4 again
probably will reach something very
similar now I could take and play 95 and
it's probably just even though
Wow takes Knight g4 if I take he takes
so clear q1 I'm gonna try I'm gonna play
h3 and kick the night no I'll take and
now I clear up c1 I'm just gonna be up
upon or more this is probably just lost
cuz the nights so bad on age 6
so please da I'll take Bishop c4 Knight
a5 I've got a 6
rook c6 now I'll play like g4 a forming
yeah why not just g4 King g7 rook this
f4
if 98 I've always got f5 so or Brooke d1
maybe yeah maybe just work do you wanna
take the amount of five and his night is
completely stuck at six now I could just
take or clay e6 no but I mean just takes
and and just takes and he's got nothing
Oh Knight c3 so he's gonna play it
differently this time Oh Bishop c4 Oh
gross why not clean cheat v e5 it's kind
of weird
Queen h5 Knight h6 I think if I take
each g5 Bishop g4 or if I play Knight e4
one second 94 issue takes
okay I don't understand this cake King D
to about bit of G for looks very
good work 93 then King D 293 maybe there
should be 5 C 6 this is very weird of
course don't really understand what's
going on but I'm attacking at least so
it's gonna be always to be easier for me
to play them for him this should be 5 C
6 takes de 5 with Chuck whoa bribes take
no it's just lost now I was up up too
much material there Qi Ayden's Bishop g4
and I could take I don't understand what
he's doing here
Bishop chief foreign - it's just over
now I could take I mean I just take the
Queen though I think
and I expect he'll resign here in a
second but
okay
hmm Nighy 8 interesting
castles wow that's bull aged six feet he
basically wants to go g5i soon but but
who might be six I think now I can play
c4 and play e5 next move and then I'm
gonna go 90 for a four was also possible
maybe a four a five
maybe I'll play a for now to try and
kick him back although he still it's
still hard to prove an advantage because
it's one very slight advantage here now
96 if he just goes rook f8 probably
although he has no no now maybe I can
just wait cuz now g7 is still hanging so
you know I'll try to f2 v that feels
wrong h5 no I fixed now he's good now
he's got the fixed weaknesses long term
here on these dark squares so I feel
like I might be better now not that it's
easy to prove anything here so it's very
very difficult but feels like there
might be some slight advantage here it
stinks but by playing a 60 fix a second
weakness now and now I'm threatening to
play Bishop III just takes e5 I don't
know what 98 does exactly but maybe he
didn't see Bishop III thought he's gonna
play b5 and 9 t b6 needn't always have
Bishop a3 now I can take bishop takes I
guess yeah why not and if he takes I
cake and then everything at the house is
all completely collapsing someone said
all I'm talking about is chess moves
sorry you guys take and now it's the
prophecy is fulfilled the weakness is
coming to play
yeah sorry guys I'm talking about the
chest moves that's I'm trying to trying
to get my rating higher than Magnus's
that's the reason I'm taking it so
seriously tonight but anyway sorry sorry
you guys if you want more more non chest
stuff
so anyway this more more scotch stuff so
I net force who's gonna take on a v6 so
I'm giving him the two bishops this time
but I feel like I've got enough play
here I'm gonna go tonight see five try
to do something on the a file or I can
even just play like Queen of six now b2
is hanging he plays queen g3 no
particular threat though so if I play
night before
now I'm threatening to take b3 b2 is
weak bishops weak I've got stuff on the
a file some slight problems here for
white that's for sure
quality humor says I'm here for your hat
collection who cares about the games
that's a good one that's a that's that's
really uh that's classic
so queen d3 now Queen B - Bishop c3
Queen g3 is getting some kind of
initiatives that I don't really want to
allow so I think I'll just take on b3
takes no I think he just blundered upon
on e4 maybe I mean queen b5 maybe rookie
for okay King h7 b4 could that be some
kind of weird trick hard to believe but
B 496 be 496 I could also play the c6
okay I've got to go for it I don't see
it so oh just be for right away okay
wait but now I've got queen bee queen
bee - Ricky a king age 7 and he's got
and he's got no no tricks I don't see
the trick so rook e8 King age 7 and I'm
not so sure
I'm not really sure what he's playing
for here like is he playing for rook e1
and Queen e8 is he playing for I don't
know cleanup one just know that's stupid
so he goes rook c1 so clearly he
miscalculated this so I'm in the
driver's seat I just need to convert it
now so I'll play Queen d4 hit the bishop
at Bishop e3 I take obviously and then I
take and pick up the rook on c1 and
anything else I can always just go a 96
night-night f8 as well which is very
important for for me in this position I
kind of think he's gonna resign here but
maybe not
but we'll see anyway let's see what he
what his next set of moves are so plays
rook d1 with no actual threats now I'm
gonna go 96 I'm just night f8 and cover
everything so c3 and just play a queenie
5 e8 9 f8 queen c8 I kind of let him
know maybe Queen d5 keep the pin alive
and now I've got rookie - if Queen c7
rookie - as pin is really really nasty
in fact I think it's just winning
completely so rook e1 I'll take and I'll
play Queen e6 and and now he can't he
can't grab my opponents he's gonna have
to exchange and I'm just up to pawns but
reverse is nighttime in know no point
playing that so alright so cakes night
c4 4 up 3 probably takes I want to play
Bishop a6 it takes tanks 94 conflict
queen g4 it's gonna be something really
weird here 6 I know he's playing
worksheet - or he's playing rook b8 okay
unless I play my faves whoa I've got to
be careful dishes make maybe castles or
maybe not there should see 394 way no 94
94 so no problem so then I just take age
7 so so here I'll play Queen h3 kick the
rook away and then I'll play 92 or d3 or
just 9 f3
maybe it's night after you make sense
so let's see d6 play work g1 dude I'll
just lick Heaney too and play for what
you want and we'll play some some
endgame again and again this is pretty
even but maybe there's some chances who
wants to go rook a six oh I'll play a
four with the idea of a five and then
tonight it's four to force him to do
something with his rook probably hold it
just exchange maybe rook c8 is gonna
play with yeah yeah rook up one rookie
four takes put his King e6 so I'm just
gonna exchange and play with the butter
pawn structure here because his pawns
are split so probably it's just a draw
again but hmm let's see if I can work
some magic here probably knocks now he's
got Bishop g5 laughs and not five law or
h5 okay what am i doing something I'm
trying to lose this or something but now
I can take and go 94 or not fly of
course I was getting into some weird
danger there by putting the knight on f2
didn't really make a whole lot of sense
maybe I can play Bishop a5 though and
hit this pawn oh and it's got d5 oh geez
nice
and terrible
so bad
and now we're gonna play something very
similar except here this works on a 1 so
DC 3 is an actual thrive
so place work D 1 which is spit weird I
mean I can take or I can play B for
maybe or I can just play something else
completely maybe maybe something else
completely
seems logically wants to go Knight f5
here I think maybe I should just drop my
work back maybe just draw up and take
and play Bishop f8 or something a4 so
I'm gonna take play B for now try try to
like a push up d4 I could also play
Knight exp for and d3 is a d3 is hanging
now so of a 3 I'll play a 5
solidify the knight on b4 take d4 I can
just take and my appears if it was
pretty good so d4 bishop c 3 t e5 pushed
a 1 d 797 that looks good
di or he is 95 wait 95 Queen e6 okay so
and I might take takes takes I'm I mean
we're gonna play some endgame now again
with what are we looking at we're
looking at two works against the Queen
now Bishop e5 is possible Bishop c3
Queen c6 probably 95 is right looks
right and takes and let's see okay so I
need to dominate his night as well maybe
this Bishop e5 protect upon this Knights
a little bit
and this is gonna be hard to win so I
better just start moving fast cuz if I
get down on the clock the the night the
queen of the night are gonna be much
much easier to play with on the other
than the rooks
maybe worked chief five first was better
but okay 93 but he's just giving me a
pond and now I can take and he has to
take with a king so his pawns are
terrible now
anyway we'll see so he's got Queenie for
I play brocade to probably maybe I have
rook a one actually Brooke a one was
better to go for work g1 and let's see
how do I do this
I just give me six or something h5 to
try and meet him
ah but now keenya strike and check and
go rook g6 maybe he's probably gonna
take I'm in a free move it just to be
safe
queenie for now I could play I thought
if maybe or just takes probably I should
just take there's a clear qi6
I mean I have no I can't lose this
position that was just clear
but whether I can actually win is a
whole different story although now he's
getting he's making it messy because I
can go work out six ah he's got clean
and eight ah and I can't I can't go back
I can't block see as that
so frustrating Pushpa 5d 595 Bishop b5
now if I take what CD doing fish takes
e4 queen d4 and I'm hitting both bishops
I've got rookie one rookie one takes
takes please got f5 and if I take e
castles wait a second wait a second so
if I plus slow this down silence over q1
take six F 5 F 3 now if I take OBD
castles no then rooks to wait but if I
take
oh man I just blender again
yeah
Oh
all right you guys this is it I mean
it's getting too tired is blundering
everywhere now yes enough yeah all right
you guys so that's just ridiculous it's
winning like the last three games and I
just uh just uh threw them all away so
yeah anyway you guys yeah it's just it's
just enough so I'll uh I'll come back
tomorrow maybe or sometime soon and play
some more but yeah it's just wondering
now so I don't really feel like
continuing so yeah anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed the stream and until until
next time keep it real